a huge buildup of Russian troops could
be seen around Ukraine's border a year
ago amid warnings they were about to
invade
then on the 24th of February it happened
with this line of armor moving from the
north towards the capital
Ukraine beat them back but battles are
still raging in the east
now this top official expects a second
Russian surge possibly even around the
anniversary
foreign
in your opinion do you think that the
worst is yet to come
um
[Music]
it's why Ukraine is desperate for more
weapons
tanks are coming and they want Jets but
it's unlikely anything will arrive fast
enough though a western official did say
they've not seen signs of Russia
planning anything specifically for the
24th of February
Moscow isn't the only one in attack mode
um
[Music]
the plan of course is to win but Russia
has the same goal Deborah Hayne Sky News
Kiev